on the 5th of january 1895 a crowd
gathered at the occult militare in paris
the historic building located at the
opposite end of the shem de mar from the
eiffel tower has seen its fair share of
military pageantry over the years but
that wasn't what they were here to
witness this day as the silent soldiers
and jeering civilians looked on captain
alfred dreyfus was led out into the
square he had been convicted of the
worst crime imaginable for a military
officer betraying his country but now he
was to pay the price a splendidly
uniformed sergeant approached dreyfuss
and began systematically ripping apart
his uniform the convict serpalets his
badges are ranked the stripes on his
trousers were torn off and tossed on the
ground in front of him his saber was
taken and broken over the sergeant's
nape then he was paraded in front of the
assembled masses allowing everyone to
get a look at the traitor and to remind
everyone what the awful cost of his
crime was the ceremony of degradation
complete alfred dreyfuss was no longer
an officer in the french army his
brethren had cast him out and now his
country would do the same he was to be
deported to prison in south america
forever banished from his home and
family it must have seemed very unfair
to alfred dreyfus after all he was
innocent he had been wrongfully
convicted he wasn't a traitor he loved
france he loved the army the problem was
nobody believed him at least not yet the
fight to clear his name would eventually
erupt into one of the biggest scandals
in french history the dreyfus affair
would polarize the entire country into
warring camps fighting at times not just
over the guilt or innocence of a single
man but it seemed for the soul of france
itself
in the last decade of the 19th century
france and germany were not exactly on
the best of terms france had been
utterly humiliated in the
franco-prussian war of 1870 being forced
to cede territory to the newly formed
german empire as well as suffering a
massive blow to their national prestige
it seemed a foregone conclusion that
hostilities would break out again so
both countries spent the following
decades in an arms race with each other
making huge strides forward in military
technology forging alliances and
crafting war plans formerly france and
germany were at peace but that didn't
stop networks of spies from operating in
both countries trying both to steal
military secrets and to protect their
own one of these spies was colonel
maximilian von schwarzkopfen
schwarzkopfen's official title was the
military attache to the german embassy
in paris but he had also been tasked by
kaiser wilhelm to collect intelligence
on french military defenses the special
interest was french artillery designs
which were at the cutting edge of
technology for the time schwarzkopfen
was a charming and sophisticated man
perfect for a diplomatic posting but he
was a remarkably careless secret agent
instead of destroying his correspondence
or locking up his important papers he
had a habit of halfheartedly tearing up
drafts or copies of letters and throwing
them in a waste basket unfortunately for
the german the embassy maid a local
parisian woman was secretly on the
payroll of the french
counterintelligence service which had
the cover name the bureau of statistics
the maid cleaned out the waste baskets
or swiped documents off of desks and
tables and then brought her findings to
her contact in the bureau who then
carefully taped the letters back
together in order to read them the
letters range from the banal to the
scandalous schwarzkopin was engaged in a
secret love affair with his counterpart
in the italian embassy alessandro
panziardi but one note known to history
as the border discovered in late
september 1894 was a letter from a spy
talking about several military documents
that had been delivered to the german
embassy along with the letter when the
document was delivered to the french
minister of war general auguste mercier
he was outraged there was a traitor
within the french army spying for the
hated germans the bureau of statistics
was given orders to find the traitor
whatever it took
on the morning of october 15 1894
captain alfred dreyfuss was summoned to
the office of the chief of the general
staff and less than an hour later was in
prison accused of betraying his country
to germany dreifus was completely
bewildered he had enjoyed a relatively
successful career in the army for the
last 15 years earning his way onto the
general staff as an artillery officer
from the very beginning he loudly
protested his innocence at every
opportunity so why was captain dreyfuss
suspected well the answer it seemed was
a simple one he was jewish jews living
in france had a considerably easier time
of things than their counterparts in
germany or russia where they were
regularly subjected to pogroms and were
largely segregated from society unlike
in those countries jews in france had
full citizenship and were active
participants in most of the nation's
professions but prejudice was
experiencing a resurgence in france in
the 1890s as anti-judaism hatred of the
jewish religion gave way to
anti-semitism hatred of the jews as a
race of people newspapers like libra
parole and lacroix routinely publish
pieces attacking jews as a malevolent
group accusing them of everything from
sacrificing christian children and blood
rituals to manipulating the continental
economy to enrich themselves and destroy
native businessmen all of french
society's ills could be blamed on the
jews and the thought of a jewish officer
betraying his country wasn't that
far-fetched to the many openly
anti-semitic members of the army
hierarchy in fact it was almost to be
expected it was in their sinister nature
according to them draper's court-martial
was held in closed session per the
army's request for reasons of national
security therefore nobody knew what
evidence had been collected against the
officer just that he was convicted and
sentenced to life in prison and a
sentence many disagreed with because
they were disappointed that dreifus
couldn't be executed for his crimes alas
that was forbidden by french law still
the punishment he was given might as
well have been a death sentence since
1852 france had been shipping her worst
prisoners to a penal colony in french
guyana it was widely considered to be
one of the worst prisons in the world
violence at the hands of other prisoners
and from guards was commonplace
facilities were primitive or
non-existent and the myriad tropical
diseases carried by mosquitoes killed
over 75 of the prisoners sent there few
people subjected to deportation ever
made it back to france after the
spectacle of the degradation ceremony
alfred dreyfus was shipped across the
atlantic to a small island 11 kilometers
off the coast of the colony known as
ilde diablo or devil's island here he
was housed totally alone except for his
guards almost completely cut off from
the outside world just meant to waste
away to nothing
massey dreyfus was alfred's older
brother he traveled to paris soon after
the family crisis began and he knew
right away that something was wrong with
this picture his brother was no traitor
he just didn't have it in him and unlike
most people he'd been in the courtroom
for alfred's court martial he knew that
the only evidence presented to implicate
his brother was the border row which
handwriting experts testified was
written by dreyfuss's hand massey didn't
think so but at first he found it very
tough to convince anyone the spark that
eventually ignited the powder keg of the
dreyfus affair appeared in march 1896
when another torn up letter was
recovered from colonel schwarzkopfen's
trash can the document known as the
petty blur because it was written on
blue paper was addressed to commandant
ferdinand olsen esterhazy another french
officer on the general staff the petty
blur ended up in the hands of lieutenant
colonel georges picard the new head of
the bureau of statistics picard acted
with more caution than his predecessor
had with dreyfus he spent months
meticulously gathering evidence against
what he believed to be a second spy for
the germans within the french army aster
hazy was a sketchy character the kind of
man who skated through life relying on
constant favors from friends and
associates and he always needed money
because he spent far more than he earned
esther hazy's motives for turning
traitor were obvious financial gain
still even while he was building a case
against esterhazy it never occurred to
bequar to question dreyfus's guilt not
until he got a hold of a sabble of
esterhazy's handwriting when he compared
it to the border piqua was shocked to
discover that the handwriting matched
exactly drapers hadn't written the
incriminating letter esther hayes he had
when the car went to his superiors with
the news that the man they had very
publicly damned as a traitor might have
been wrongfully convicted they were less
than impressed after all admitting they
had made a mistake would humiliate the
army's leaders in front of the entire
country careers would be ruined officers
might even be prosecuted after all both
the general staff and picard knew that a
secret file compiled by the bureau of
statistics had been given to the
military judges at dreyfuss's court
martial after they had retired for
deliberations this bar was not entered
into evidence and was completely unknown
to the defense of flagrant violation of
the law picar's orders from his
superiors were clear bury the new
evidence what had started as a simple
case of mistaken identity was now a
full-blown criminal conspiracy and picar
was having none of it the war was on
[Music]
when it became clear to the general
staff that colonel picard wasn't going
to play ball with them they set out to
ruin first by transferring him to
tunisia and then by bringing him up on
trumped-up charges picard fought back
going first to sympathetic politicians
and then to the press with his
allegations at the same time matty
dreyfus mounted his own separate press
campaign insisting that there was
something wrong with his brother's
verdict more and more attention was
being brought what was now being called
the dreifus affair or simply le faire
public opinion was sharply divided on
one side were the dre facades who
supported reopening the case in light of
the new evidence and on the other were
the anti-dre facades who wanted the
conviction to be upheld anti-semitism
was central to the belief system of the
anti-dre facades stoked by virulent
rhetoric published in right-wing
newspapers the general staff leaned into
this hatred of the jews by openly
promoting the idea that they were
combating a vast jewish conspiracy a
syndicate who wanted to set dreyfus free
despite him being guilty of treason why
esterhazy's name began to circulate
among the dreyfussads as being the real
spy the general staff made the
incredible decision to protect him
sending a liaison officer to him with
advice to keep his mouth shut then when
the calls for action became too loud to
ignore they brought him to trial but his
court martial was a share his acquittal
was guaranteed before it even started so
to recap in order to hide the fact that
they had wrongfully convicted an
innocent man the army had deliberately
acquitted someone they knew to be guilty
for noted dre facade emile zola this was
the last straw zola was one of the most
celebrated authors of his day his novels
were widely read throughout europe
despite this he put his career and
reputation at risk to defend dreyfus
penning an open letter to the president
of france and publishing it in the
newspaper le aurore on january 13 1898.
under the headline jacuzz zola laid out
all of the accusations against the army
detailing for the first time to the
french public the depths of the
conspiracy to keep dreyfus in jail
jacuzz struck france like a bolt of
lightning people were shocked by the
dramatic reveal as well as the
subsequent trial of zola for libel when
zola's lawyer attempted to prove the
allegations laid out in the article zola
was ultimately convicted of libel and
sentenced to a year in jail the jury
unwilling to believe that the army one
of the most well-respected institutions
in the country would engage in such
conduct
alfred dreyfus had no idea at the battle
that was being waged on his behalf on
devil's island the prisoner was kept in
complete isolation his mail censored so
that details of his case never reached
him he lived in a tin roofed shack
surrounded by a stockade which did
nothing to keep out the oppressive heat
or the swarms of insects that attacked
him regularly his health steadily
deteriorated and his family were worried
that he would die over there before
being rehabilitated at this point it
seemed like the anti-dre facades had one
picar was discredited zola always a
convicted libeler esterhazy was quietly
retired from the army and left the
country and dreyfus was no closer to
retrial than he had been in 1894. but
the army's conspiracy was a house of
cards and one of their own was about to
inadvertently collapse the entire thing
the new minister of war gotta
forecavaniac was a fierce anti-dre
facade who took office with one goal in
mind to smash any doubt in the minds of
the french public about the guilt of
dreyfus to that end he ordered the
secret file containing more than 300
documents that were supposed to
definitively prove that dreyfus was a
spy to be opened and its contents
expertly evaluated this backfired
spectacularly on the army as it was soon
discovered that the only document in the
file that specifically mentioned dreyfus
by name a letter supposedly written by
the italian military attache was a
crudely constructed forgery to his
credit kavanagh didn't do what his
predecessors would have done that is
cover it all up instead he revealed the
forgery and conducted an investigation
into where it came from to the horror of
the anti-trade facades colonel uber
joseph orri who had been instrumental in
both the conviction of dreyfus and the
destruction of piccar was compelled to
confess to making the forgery on august
31 1898 a day after confessing to his
crime ori committed suicide by slitting
his throat with a razor the scandal
compelled the chief of general staff to
resign and revive the cause of the jury
facades over the course of the next year
three different prime ministers resigned
as their governing coalitions collapsed
and multiple officials quit their posts
the president of france died and his
successor was assaulted while attending
a horse race anti-semitic riots tore
through the country and there was an
attempted coup d'etat in february 1899
that failed after receiving no support
from the army it seemed like the
republic itself was under threat
attacked by a right-wing faction that
was both anti-semitic and anti-drafzard
to stop the chaos a new governing
coalition of republican defense was
formed in 1899 led by pierre walder
rousseau one of the first things on his
agenda settling the dravers affair once
and for all
[Music]
in june 1899 dravis conviction was set
aside by the supreme court and the man
at the center of a national fuhrer left
devil's island after four years of
torture to return to france he was to be
tried once again by military court
martial this time in the city of ren the
trial began on august 7 1899. many
people were shocked by the horrible
condition dreyfus was in his new uniform
flapped around his skeletal frame and he
looked like it aged 20 years the legal
drama that unfolded over the following
weeks was the 19th century equivalent of
the o.j simpson trial in terms of
international interest not only was all
of france riveted to the coverage of the
action in the newspapers but so was the
rest of europe and dispatches about each
day of the trial were sent across the
transatlantic telegraph cable to north
america as well it soon became apparent
to neutral observers just how flimsy the
prosecution's case against dreyfus
actually was the entire first trial had
revolved around draper's supposed
authorship of the border but now five
years later hardly anyone actually
believed that dreyfus had actually
written the letter the handwriting
expert whose testimony was crucial in
1894 was discredited after a number of
ridiculous comments including an
assertion that traifors had learned how
to forge his own handwriting esther hazy
who did not appear at the wren trial now
admit an impress interviews to write in
the note in question though he asserted
he only did to it the direction of
french intelligence and the fact that an
admitted forger colonel orri had handled
the document meant that it couldn't be
assured that it hadn't been tampered
with without the border row the rest of
the case against dreyfus seemed to fall
apart however the defense was her by
disorganization on the part of dreyfus's
attorneys it definitely didn't help that
one of the lawyers was shot in the back
by a would-be assassin on his way to
court a weak into the trial and in any
case dreyfus wasn't being tried by a
civilian court he was being tried by the
army and the army remained firmly behind
general mercier the war minister who had
overseen dreyfus's first conviction and
was just as sure of his guilt the second
time around when dreyfuss was convicted
again on september the 9th and sentenced
to 10 years imprisonment the dre facades
were shocked perhaps they shouldn't have
been at this point to the anti-dre
facades it didn't seem to matter whether
the man was actually guilty or not it
was all about the honor of the army
which apparently demanded that dreyfuss
be convicted regardless of the evidence
travis's second conviction sparked
international outcry france was accused
of being an arbitrary state contrary to
its supposed ideals even france's
closest ally russia ruled by one of
europe's last absolute monarchs thought
the verdict was wrongly decided there
was serious talk of boycotting the
world's fair to be held in paris the
next year prime minister waldek rousseau
had had enough he offered a compromise
instead of going through the ordeal of a
second retrial he offered dreyfus a
pardon that would free him immediately
unfortunately accepting a pardon also
requires a convicted person to accept
guilt for the crimes that they're being
pardoned for despite being initially
reluctant dreyfus ultimately accepted
leaving prison for the last time on
september 21 1899. it was a bitter pill
for the dre facades to swallow
especially when coupled with an amnesty
law passed in november that not only
cleared piccar and zola but also
prevented any of the conspirators that
had committed crimes to put dreifus in
prison from ever facing accountability
for it some of the more committed trey
facades who viewed the movement more as
one of social change than a campaign to
write the act of one injustice turned on
dreyfuss after he accepted the pardon
feeling like he had betrayed their cause
but it's hard to blame the man who after
all was innocent for not turning down a
chance to escape the hell he'd spent the
last five years in draper's hadn't
signed up for martyrdom all he wanted to
do was go home to his family most people
in his position would have probably done
the same thing
on july the 12th 1906 alfred dreyfus's
conviction at ren was officially quashed
by the supreme court this time there
would be no retrial dravis's 12-year
long legal ordeal was over by this time
the old leadership of the army had been
swept away replaced by a new generation
that wasn't so entrenched in their own
mystique to admit when a mistake had
been made organized anti-semitism had
largely fallen apart in france by 1902
and though it has never gone away it has
never again been embraced so openly by
the country not even when occupied by
the nazis during world war ii georges
pacar would eventually serve as minister
of war after being exonerated in the
amnesty of 1899. ferdinand esterhazy
would die in 1923 still in exile in
england under an assumed name alfred
dreyfuss was promoted to commandant the
day after his exoneration reflecting the
rank he would have had if his career
hadn't been disrupted he was also
decorated with the legion of honor the
only attempt at restitution that france
would ever give him the days of
multi-million euro settlements being
decades away not surprisingly drapers
didn't serve long in the army that had
betrayed him so viciously after being
rehabilitated retiring a year later he
returned to service during the first
world war seeing combat of adol among
other places he retired again in 1919 as
a colonel dreyfuss never really
recovered his health from his time spent
on devil's island his hair returned
permanently white and he was susceptible
to fevers and fatigue his sleep was
plagued by nightmares most likely caused
by untreated traumatic stress disorder
he was completely unable to separate
himself from the affair that had
consumed his life in 1908 while
attending the interment ceremony of emil
zola's remains in the pantheon in paris
anti-dre facade fnatic fired two shots
at him wounding him in the arm in the
last act of judicial bitterness the man
was acquitted after claiming he only
meant to wound dreyfus and wasn't trying
to kill him he died in 1935 quietly at
home surrounded by his family two days
later his funeral possession passed by
splendid formations of soldiers on its
way to his final resting place at
paris's montparnasse cemetery it was
bastille de france's national holiday a
celebration of the military glory of the
republic it was a fitting end for
someone who wanted nothing else but to
just be another french soldier before
his life was completely derailed by one
of the world's most famous miscarriages
of justice
[Music]
you